he's my perfect match he really is just
so incredible so supportive loyal kind
paris hilton is a married woman the
heiress in her boo kartareem have
officially tied the knot my best friend
and my
prince charming all rolled into one the
two were engaged in february after a
year of dating and e.t kept tabs on all
the wedding planning
debbie nailed down the dress just yet
yes but it's a surprise you know i'm not
your traditional bride although the 40
year old might not be sticking strictly
to tradition she revealed plans to take
her hubby's last name on her podcast
this is paris
i'm going to take it but don't worry
she's not getting rid of hilton instead
she'll hyphenate and go by paris hilton
ring
there were a number of celebrations
leading up to the nuptials just landed
in vegas
including a joint bachelor and
bachelorette party in las vegas which
the dj documented on instagram
[Music]
[Applause]
and a star-studded alice in wonderland
inspired bridal bash with her mom kathy
hilton aunt kyle richards as well as a
few familiar faces from the real
housewives of beverly hills i was so
excited ahead of the wedding a source
told e.t that quote paris and carter
can't wait to marry each other but
wedding planning has been a bit
stressful and hectic there's a lot so
i'm really excited to share that with
all my fans does this mean the wedding
is televised yes according to paris fans
will get an inside look into the
planning and wedding itself when her new
reality series paris in love premieres
on peacock
you're gonna make me cry back in june
the reality star opened up to e.t about
what it means to have a man like her
husband carter by her side he's
i've never
met a man like this in my life and i've
been with someone who loves and supports
me so much and lifts me up and
isn't intimidated and
is just
like my best friend and my
prince charming all rolled into one and
always by my side every time what we've
went to anywhere that has to do with
what i'm doing for my activism he's
always by my side and
i'm just so blessed and i can't wait for
the next step in our life